[Music]
and killer troll news Kenneth trolls
semi-people a Japanese blogging was
stabbed to death shortly after giving a
lecture about online abuse oh so you
don't want to get abused online
well obvious you impersonate me was this
person in a public place
yes I talk about online of this business
here and in the States or in Japan see
if the Yakuza was doing a better job
yeah they would not be an issue
yep but the yaku son is dying out now
sometimes I just wait for you to comment
on somebody else's [ __ ] curse your makes
me laugh like what like what you comment
on my show you just laugh yeah use like
causes them stupid [ __ ] comment like
her post or like the DS but [ __ ] maybe
laugh there because it's so unwarranted
his comments what is he saying oh my god
pasta that one balcony one and I said
something like wishing I could wake up
to this view again or some like that he
was like I was wearing a dress you slept
in a dress well the day me is like
coming back to YouTube aren't you too
old for this [ __ ] is because when you
follow people their comments like pop up
people that you follow yeah whatever he
write something guys delete it before
you post just block him post it let it
sit there for a day or two and then ah
yeah so this Japanese bloggers well
people just set themselves up for the
alley-oop we just got a dunk like they
post it and then their toy please
comment and smash me down fine it's so
Roseworthy you know you roast yourself
or like or you make it really lu pible
not a tell you okay whatever I give up
[Laughter]
so yeah this definitely Slugger cares he
was stabbed to death by an internet
troll that he had feuded with online
also he's not an internet troll then
that he's a real true yes it was not a
keyboard warrior it's a real world legit
yeah like thought about and he's a hater
this [ __ ] [ __ ] sucks I commend him
cuz instead of [ __ ] talking [ __ ] from
behind a keyboard he's actually down for
this [ __ ] yeah he's about that laughs
[ __ ] psychotic then I go to me it
depends on how he did it because it's
like if he's like surprise [ __ ] then
the guy it wasn't a fair fight he's
still being a little [ __ ] about it like
oh so what if like like I hated Noah
and he's like vlogging and [ __ ] and I
[ __ ] scope them out and I just ran up
and I ran away he never got to use his
karate skills yeah there's no fair
warning fair yeah it's still like a
[ __ ] drive-by comment that's why you
need to try but it's still better than
like you [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll kick your
ass
any day over and then you see him like
at the supermarket oh [ __ ] when you
[ __ ] go hide somewhere because what
if his comment was like if I ever see
you in public I'm gonna stab you and run
away that's a good comment and he's
about that life ah that's still [ __ ]
wild he's pissed being a man of his word
versus like a lot of people they just
talk hellish it and they don't bow I
mean if like what [ __ ] is so offensive
that you need to go out of your way to
kill someone no I mean we're not saying
it's right we're just saying like he's
legit because he's psycho oh for sure he
is okay I think that's what we all
understand and agree everyone we're just
saying that I know but you guys don't
explain it you guys went into says it's
[ __ ] up right off the bat and no one
heard though it's [ __ ] like it's
[ __ ] up he's psycho I'm still gonna
give him a trophy yeah you almost had me
there man you you bet you want the walk
you don't just talk the talk even though
whatever you walk is [ __ ] crazy but
you walk the watch all I'm saying is
he's the kind of guy that commits to a
contract
contrary she's binding for this guy
[ __ ] good though guy I commend you
yeah that's horrible man so this man is
an unemployed man 42 years old he was
this infamous troll online and victim 41
years old she was a Tokyo based internet
security provider he worked with
Internet security and so he was doing
this two-hour lecture and so this dude
went to his two-hour lecture
waited had a knife in his bag and then
when he got the opportunity he stabbed
him multiple times in the neck in the
chest and I was the first time they ever
met online because the victim apparently
had condemned his internet trolling and
so he built up a grudge against him and
killed him
damn that is [ __ ] psycho he's
dedicating his life to Internet security
and anti-bullying and trolling and he
got attacked by a [ __ ] terrorist he
looks like a [ __ ] terrorist look at
that [ __ ] that's the attacker that
fool looks like he loves karaoke first I
know it looks like the other guy was a
troll and this guy was I don't know they
both look like they could be friends to
his feelings got hurt so bad that he's
stabbed in the dead cuz feelings got
hurt you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah he's a
little [ __ ] let me troll anymore look
at [ __ ] yeah that's pretty crazy then
they found he admitted to it and he said
like I thought I would kill him whoa
damn he's like I held a grudge against
him over the internet exchanges and this
is the first killing he's ever done see
now I'm sad because sometimes I make fun
of people that try to troll when I'm
taking a poopy on the toilet yeah now if
Rama gets that now but good for you take
it more time
yeah but boy Titus do anything is a
knife that's true you're good kick you
can kick somebody and endo just fabulous
but there's so much adrenaline you're
not gonna fill it until after you kick
their ass
apparently he ambushed the victim for
playing here's to the bathroom after you
don't go to the bathroom yeah hold wear
a diaper oh yeah you got to learn ronk
want also to though I'm always scared
I'm gonna get stabbed so my sense is be
up all the time though like that do it
in another video
you said that your senses are down now
what is it refuting they're always fun
this is what the truth is they're never
up but sometimes they are they're never
there sometimes they're up that's what
it is you just said never though this is
what it is
they're never up a sometimes zero that's
gonna just don't leave it at that mine
are always up and down I've never a hole
but sometimes I mahal see what it is is
that you get so comfortable living in
such a nice neighborhood you think the
whole world is like that and then you go
back to your old neighborhood and you
realize you could die yeah like what
happen to you recently right like it's
so weird uh but like when that homeless
guy was coming after me you know you get
which I was there um but that's too
apparent I don't have that subtle thing
anymore where I'm always worried about
my hometown
oh yeah that's [ __ ] I don't like that
either I'm saying yeah it's not that
it's not safe for me out there dude
that's why we'll stay in South Pasadena
for the rest of my life well if you want
to find David killers Pasadena there's
cops everywhere and there's cameras
everywhere I don't know I don't think I
have any haters I only have lovers only
I did like four years ago and I invited
him to the Clarks but I don't know why
haters change when you DM them
personally cuz it's too real yeah it's
not public anywhere they're not trying
to be hard that's what I say he's about
that way I said let's go and hang out at
the park and we can talk about it did
you really yeah oh [ __ ] and then they
just kept dragging it on do you guys
leave stuff in your car ever like what
stuff like bags bags
yeah bags smelly James do you want us to
promote all the [ __ ] that we have said
the feel of it yeah they could steal my
smelly underwear so they could [ __ ]
put it in their mouth while they [ __ ]
masturbate Oh leave bags yeah what did
you hear I want it I know I just don't
know I don't even know what it's tongs
why would I leave like empty plastic
bags in my car oh my what the hell not
for the hajima pictured a grocery bag
yeah I just picture like a bunch of
grocery bags just all lined up with all
empty sitting there like upright oh my
gosh why why are they uh did you guys
communicate that yeah what are you gonna
take the garbage why would I steal my
own garbage look
the Bucks do zone garbage you dumb [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
I'll take your tiger to another hole get
funny Till's crazy stealing garbage I
don't mind if people steal my [ __ ] it's
just material [ __ ] [ __ ] you yes you do
you said you felt violated like it was
women [ __ ] up when I was a kid but now
it's like someone broke into my car
might time to take a selfie for
Instagram it's funny well just to put it
out there the blue car don't break into
that one that one's mine don't break you
think you could break into my other
tooth like no matter what but if I'm gay
imma kill you as a kid just when your
ever you had a card you just never leave
your [ __ ] in there no matter what you're
supposed to put the [ __ ] wheel lock
on it and all that yes I don't do the
club anymore but no one does the club
you know what the club is right yeah
yeah would mean you're supposed to I'm
saying that's what we were taught to do
put the club on the wheel yeah that's
why I'm saying so I don't do that
anymore but I never leave stuff in my
car ever or if I do have to go somewhere
in the grocery store I always put it
under the seat you just leave the
[ __ ] keys in the car and walk away
okay well first of all the only time I
did that was because I was getting a
haircut and I had drove a Tesla for so
long I left the car on with the key yeah
so this is what happened right so I
think I'm making it this is what happens
so I've been driving the tester for so
long and I just got the hon element
right and so even sad nobody took the
[ __ ] car with no one in it I was on
and saying take me please listen to me
so I went to go get a haircut you know I
got faded up took about 45 minutes to an
hour I come back outside and I hear the
car rumbling I'm like dude this cars
[ __ ] up I got a lemon like it just
turns on automatically right and so I go
inside and I'm looking inside and I'm
like yeah what the [ __ ] you just call
hot an ism why is it making so much
noise why is the [ __ ] engine running
I look inside the key is in the ignition
and the cars turned on and I left the
car on completely and ready to go like a
gift and I was so pissed I was so
embarrassed I didn't post understand
that the Honda Element even the wheels
were turns outwards so so much
it wasn't one of the most completely
moments of my life because my car was on
I love your confusing face because you'd
like you do this and like you're sat in
the car and I couldn't figure it out I
was like I was sitting in the car
looking around I like put the ball
you're blaming the car yeah this piece
of [ __ ] turned off by itself
yeah Lizzie's cars rumbling for no
reason it being like oh [ __ ] I left it
on it's like what why is it on it's
never my chemical issue
[Laughter]
[Music]